[Music]
whether you're a longtime zelda fan or a
newcomer to the series chances are
you're at least familiar with the lost
woods it's a recurring location dating
back all the way to the very first title
and has always had a sense of mystery
attached to it its reputation is mainly
that of a dense forbidden forest that is
hard to navigate causing some to get
lost hence the name there have been
quite a lot of iterations of the lost
woods each with their own rules
atmosphere and end goal sometimes it's
the resting place of the master sword
sometimes it houses a dungeon or both it
differs for each game now in most games
the forest is simply very confusing and
those who are unlucky or ill-prepared
run the risk of becoming irreversibly
lost forever never to be seen again but
there's one version of the lost woods
that stands out from all the others that
being the one from ocarina of time the
reason it stands out is because here the
punishment for getting lost is a lot
more severe and honestly quite
disturbing getting lost and potentially
dying of exhaustion dehydration or
starvation is already bad enough but in
ocarina of time legends say that those
who find themselves lost will be cursed
to wander the forest for all eternity
but is any of this true are the souls of
the unfortunate really wandering the
forest or are these simply old folk
tales perhaps to deter people from
setting foot inside a way to protect the
forest and the secrets that lie within
as far as the claims about the lost
woods go there's only one example of
something close to a first-hand witness
account that potentially proves the
validity of these stories an individual
who's been bold enough or reckless
enough to venture inside the forbidden
parts of the forest never to be seen
again this will be a two-part theory
about the lost woods in ocarina of time
and to a smaller extent majora's mask in
today's video we'll be looking at the
woods themselves and the stories
surrounding them and in part 2 which
will be released soon after we will
attempt to shed some light on the
missing person's case and the mysterious
circumstances surrounding his
disappearance based on today's findings
so sit back relax and let's dive into
the curse of the lost woods
[Music]
the stories surrounding the lost woods
are not as straightforward as it may
seem there is a degree of uncertainty
misunderstandings and even contradictory
information about the rules the sacred
forest abides to especially when it
comes to some of the consequences and
punishment the forest as a whole is made
up of three primary locations the kokiri
forest where the children of the forest
live the lost woods themselves and the
sacred forest meadow which also houses
the ever so mysterious forest temple
although separate areas each of these
locations ultimately makes up the forest
as a whole so when people in the game
talk about the forest they can be
referring to any of these locations the
kokiri forest is as stated before the
home of the forest children known as the
one thing to note right off the bat is
that yes the kokiri are the same
entities as the koroks who show up for
the first time in the wind waker here
it's explained that after the events of
ocarina of time the kokiri took on the
form of the koroks following the great
flood we even meet the ghost of a sage
who is confirmed to be the ancestor of
the koroks who still takes on the form
of a kokiri child akin to the ones from
ocarina of time one rule states that the
children of the forest can never leave
the area as they will die if they do but
there's been a lot of debate about how
this even works and if it's even true to
begin with the biggest reason why people
have put this into question is because
during the credits of ocarina of time
the kokiri are seen celebrating
alongside the other inhabitants of
hyrule and this celebration takes place
on long long range far outside the
forest now there could be many reasons
why this is possible nobody ever makes
it clear how and why a kokiri would die
if they step outside the forest the
kokiri themselves take it very seriously
and seem to think that it spells instant
death for them if they try but again we
never see the effect it has on them some
suggest that they simply lose their
immortality if they leave and grow old
and die others think that because the
kokiri are vulnerable children the
dangers of the outside world is what
gets them yet others claim that this
entire story is simply a lie made up by
the deku tree to discourage them from
leaving i myself think it's a
combination of the last two the story
may have indeed been made up it wouldn't
be the first time that the deku tree
used a white lie to keep secrets case
and point being link's true origin as a
hylian which he didn't disclose until
after link was already an adult and
never told any of the other kokiri about
it this was of course to link's own
benefit he sensed great destiny in him
and wanted to keep him safe until he was
ready to fulfill said destiny the deku
tree's purpose is protecting and
watching over the forest and the spirits
that dwell within and it's likely that a
kokiri out on his own would run the risk
of death if faced with monsters or other
threats from the outside world i however
don't think that there's any magic
involved where a kokiri would magically
drop dead upon leaving the forest or
lose their immortality and die a slow
death and there's a couple of reasons
why i think this is not the case the
first is that there's no evidence of a
kokiri who lost our immortality in any
of the games we never meet a former
kokiri who has chosen a mortal life
outside the forest second is the fact
that in every other game the spirits of
the forest are able to leave just fine
in fact in the case of the wind waker
the deku tree even encourages them to
leave to
well spread his seed so the forest can
expand and of course in breath of the
wild they're all over the place lastly
there's a gossip stone right outside
link's house which says they say that
one kokiri has left the forest but he's
still alive now of course this could be
referring to link himself but there are
some problems with that idea the gossip
stone is already there before link
leaves the forest first of all and
second link isn't a kokiri he's a hylian
so could it be that this gossip stone
isn't referring to link and is instead
talking about a real kokiri who secretly
left the forest one day and has lived to
tell the tale maybe but as to who this
mysterious kokiri would be is anyone's
guess so whether true or not this is the
rule set to apply to those who call the
forest home but what about the other way
around what happens to outsiders trying
to enter well this is where we get to
the most notorious part about the lost
woods in ocarina of time it is said that
those from the outside world who enter
the forest and end up getting lost will
transform into a monster and find
themselves trapped here forever
additionally their age will dictate what
shape they will take on lost children
are set to transform into a skull kid
little forest imps made of wood and if
it's an adult they will take on the form
of a stealthos the wandering remains of
a skeleton turn to a hostile monster
again we have to ask ourselves is any of
this true do outsiders really transform
into cursed monstrosities or is it
potentially yet another lie or fairy
tale this time to keep people out as
opposed to keeping them in let's start
with the skull kids one theory i
disagree with is the idea that kokiri
who get lost in the woods turn into
skull kids i've read about this idea in
a couple of different places most
notably on zelda wiki which says that
quote there's speculation about whether
or not kokiri or hylian children turn
into skull kids it is more plausible
that kokiri turn into skull kids due to
the fact that they stay children for
their whole lives and it further states
that quote skull kids appear to be made
of wood and later games make it clear
that kokiri are related to the tree like
koroks who also hide their faces with
masks and yes there are some
similarities between the koroks and the
skull kids but for me personally it's
not enough to come to this conclusion
i'd even argue that there's more
evidence that contradicts it we know for
a fact that the skull kids and the
kokiri have a friendly relationship with
each other they are said to play with
them and zarya has even taught her
famous song to one of them this is also
confirmed to be the very same skull kid
who later plays a big role in majora's
mask at the end of the game he remarks
that link has the same smell as the
fairy kid who taught him a song in the
woods that fairy kid of course being
saria who did indeed teach him the song
and was allegedly even friends with him
as mido points out that she only taught
the song to close friends so as far as
counter evidence goes if the lost woods
are so dangerous that they could make a
kokiri who accidentally makes a wrong
turn transform into a skull kid why
would the deku tree allow them to go
inside in the first place because that's
what they do zarya has our own secret
spot in the forest meadow and both mido
and fedo are seen visiting the lost
woods as well on top of that one of them
even says to link if you're looking for
sarya she's in the lost woods as usual i
know you'll get lost but don't worry
you'll just end up back at the entrance
i doubt that if the kokiri ran any risk
of being cursed and turned into a skull
kid they would be so casual about it
some have used this line from one of the
kokiri as evidence that one of the quote
unquote forest kids was complaining
about their face some seem to think that
they are referring to a kokiri who was
complaining about their face and because
there's a skull kid who does something
similar that skull kid must have been a
former kokiri that they knew but if you
ask me it's pretty obvious that they are
simply referring directly to the skull
kid and not one of their kokiri friends
the term forest kid is probably just a
name that the kokiri used to describe
them it's clearly meant to be a hint as
to who to sell the skull mask to in
kakariko village we find a similar hint
about the kid from the graveyard lastly
there is a gossip stone that sheds some
more light on the story about the lost
woods stating that they say that when
non-fairy folk enter the lost woods they
become monsters the term non-fairy folk
is of course already pretty damning for
the kokiri skull kit theory but it's
also important to note that skull kids
are not monsters they are spirits
something we'll get back to later for
now let's move on to adults and their
transformation into stealthos
the lore behind this transformation
stems from a conversation with one of
the kokiri girls inside the lost woods
there's two versions of this
conversation one from the original and
one from the 3ds title which is slightly
different on the n64 she says anybody
who comes into the forest will be lost
everybody will become a stealthos
everybody stealthos but on the 3ds she
says except for the kokiri people who
come into the forest end up lost they
all become stealthos notice that on the
3ds they added the phrase except for the
kokiri another reason to believe that
the kokiri are not the ones who get lost
and turn into skull kids this
conversation also ties directly into our
missing person's case which we'll cover
next time but let's just say for now
that his disappearance stands as the
most compelling piece of evidence that
at least parts of the legends about the
lost woods may in fact be true and that
he has indeed been lost to the forest
cursed to live his life as a skeletal
monstrosity for who knows how long maybe
until link or someone else puts him out
of his misery but there's a couple of
things that never sat right with me
regarding this case and maybe there's a
lot more to it than we are led to
believe it doesn't have to be of course
maybe the simplest answer is also the
right one but this wouldn't be much of a
theory video if we didn't at least try
to come up with an alternative the first
and most obvious question people have
asked is of course why do the lost woods
not affect link i mean he is a hylian
after all but to be fair i don't think
this necessarily takes away from the
possibility that the lost woods are
indeed cursed because the gossip stone
we mentioned earlier does clearly say
that non-fairy folk are said to turn
into monsters and link does have a fairy
it's easy to believe that guardian
fairies can somehow protect their
companion against the curse what it
doesn't explain however is how hylians
and perhaps other races were able to
build all these structures inside the
forest there's man-made entrances to
zora's domain and goron city as well as
of course the huge forest temple if the
woods are cursed how did they manage to
build all of this and not get affected
by it now you might say well maybe the
curse didn't go into effect until after
the forest temple fell but that doesn't
seem to add up either after all some of
the skull kids particularly the one from
majira's mask have been around since
ancient times this means that if the
stories about children turning into
skull kids are true the curse has to
have been around for a very very long
time now the forest temple is very much
haunted by ghosts and monsters including
stealthos but the general consensus is
that this is because a battle took place
here and the temple was at some point
invaded leading to the demise of its
occupants who then continued to linger
inside their resurrection may have even
been solely ganondorf's doing as sarya
does state that the temple has only
recently become infested by monsters the
stories surrounding the forest temple
are too much to cover in this video but
if you want to check out some cool
theories about it i will add one by
vortexi gaming as well as one from
celtic in the description below either
way it's clear that there has been
highly inactivity in the lost woods
possibly as late as the hyrulean civil
war which ended only a few years before
link started his adventure while the
presence of stalfos inside the forest
temple does seem to hint that the curse
is real this isn't the only option if
adults who enter the forest indeed turn
into stealthos how come we only find
them inside the temple and nowhere else
in the forest why are they also found
inside the shadow temple and ganon's
castle among other places before we can
try to answer these questions we first
have to determine what a stalfose even
is in the first place the game itself
doesn't have much to say about them
other than how to defeat it but i did
find two passages in hyrule historia and
encyclopedia two books which seem to be
a bit at odds with each other when it
comes to the lore behind the stalfos
historia simply repeats what's already
been established by the game itself that
adults turn into stealthos and children
into skull kids and that both are doomed
to wander the woods however encyclopedia
adds to the stealthos lore and suggests
that they are specifically the
resurrected remains of soldiers who fell
in battle they have retained parts of
their memory in particular their combat
skills now normally i'm not one to
choose a book over a game but since the
game doesn't have much to say about the
stealthos for the theory at hand i think
it's fair to at least take the books
into consideration while they do without
a doubt hold information that is
questionable possible retcons or
flat-out mistakes at the same time
there's also plenty of stuff that has
been accepted as canon like you know the
official zelda timeline or the fact that
the hero shade is the hero of time which
was just a theory until the book
confirmed it obviously i'm biased
because i'm trying to build a theory so
take it with a grain of salt but for now
let's go with the notion that stalfos
are indeed dead soldiers to me this
simply makes the most sense given their
weapons and combat skills this makes the
appearance of stealth in places like
gannon's castle the shadow temple and
forest temple make perfect sense these
would have been locations where soldiers
were to be stationed a wartime prison
for the enemies of the royal family the
remains of hyrule castle which
previously housed plenty of soldiers and
a mysterious stronghold inside a forest
where a battle took place so then why
would our missing person turn into a
stealthos he's not a soldier we know
that you'd expect him to turn into a
re-dead or something in fact he already
looks a bit like a redead we also never
actually witness him as a stealth foes
in the game even after clearing the
forest temple first nor do we see other
stealthos outside the forest temple so
could it be that the legends behind the
stealthos and maybe even the skull kit
transformations are in fact just that
legends we've already demonstrated that
the stories about the kokiri dying when
they leave the forest could have been a
lie this opens up the possibility that
the same thing applies to the mythos
surrounding the lost woods at the very
least it could have been a
misinterpretation people undoubtedly
went missing in the forest and were
never seen again maybe people witnessed
skull kids and the stalfos in and around
the forest temple and simply drew the
conclusion that these must be the
remains of these missing people while in
fact the two could be unrelated similar
to those who are said to be the spirits
of the undead unable to move on to the
afterlife because of hatred or
unfulfilled desires maybe stealthos are
indeed the remains of dead soldiers who
are also unable to find peace after they
perished in battle as for the skull kids
they could simply be just another type
of forest spirit just like the kokiri
and may have no connection to hylian
children at all spirits come in all
sorts of different forms in the zelda
universe from dragons to great fairies
little woodland imps to other mysterious
creatures not saying that skull kids
cannot possibly have been hylian
children in their past lives i'm just
saying that it could also be a myth no
skull kid has ever shed light on what
they are who they were in a past life or
anything else about their kind they are
to this day a bit of an enigma so it's
not hard to believe that the hylians may
have misunderstood them and made up
stories about their origin due to a lack
of knowledge the use of words like it is
said and they say does seem to reflect
that these are stories being passed down
and not necessarily solid facts it is of
course also noteworthy that this is the
only game where the lost woods act this
way in any other game it's just a
mysterious place where people can
potentially get lost there's no mentions
of transforming into the undead or
becoming spirits or anything else like
it in a link to the past some people
like thieves even live and hide inside
the forest to avoid persecution i do
realize that not all iterations of the
lost woods are the same place but it is
a bit strange that this legendary curse
only exists here and nowhere else so are
the lost woods cursed we may never know
for sure the fact that people have been
speculating and debating these mysteries
for so many years is a testament to the
fact that the game doesn't spell it out
clear as day although the disappearance
of one of the game's npcs is definitely
suspicious like i said we never actually
witnessed them turning into a stalfos
all we have is hearsay and as we all
know not every story told ends up being
true so in the next video we'll take a
closer look at our missing persons case
we'll look at their background and the
circumstances and do a little sherlock
holmes detective work to see if there's
more to this story than we initially
thought until then i hope to see you in
the next video this is dawn signing off
and have a good one
[Music]
do
[Music]
you